This week, we will
consider the special case
of circular motion.
The case where we know that the
motion is exactly constrained
to have a circular geometry.
This will consist of two parts.
First, we will consider the
kinematics of circular motion.
How do we describe the
trajectory, velocity,
and acceleration of a particle
undergoing circular motion?
We will consider
both the simple case
of uniform circular motion,
where the object moves
with constant speed, and also
nonuniform circular motion,
where the object is speeding
up and/or slowing down
as a function of time.
We will see that a
Cartesian coordinate
system proves awkward for
describing circular motion.
And instead, we will introduce
the so-called polar coordinate
system in terms of
the radius vector
from the origin and its
position angle, which
provides a much more
elegant description
for circular motion.
We will then examine the
dynamics of circular motion
using Newton's second law to
understand what sorts of forces
are required in order to
cause circular motion in both
the uniform and
nonuniform cases.
This will be the first
of several examples
we will see in this course
of constrained motion.
In this case, the constraint
is that the object
moves in a circular path.